- [Instructor] Hello everyones.
Today we are going to be
talking about heat capacity,
also known as thermal capacity.
Now this is just the
amount of heat required
to change the temperature of a material.
So given this definition,
what units would you expect
heat capacity to have?
Heat is a form of energy
and we're describing how
much of that is needed
to change the temperature,
so the units for heat capacity
are energy per temperature,
in SI would be Joules per Kelvin.
Now, remember, in SI we
use Kelvin for temperature,
which is the same in magnitude as Celsius.
So a difference of 1 degree Celsius
is equal to a difference of 1 Kelvin,
however, Kelvin does not
have any negative numbers,
and so 0 Kelvin is as low as you can get.
Now, you probably already have
an intuitive understanding
of heat capacity
even if you haven't heard it phrased
exactly like this before.
Imagine you have two pots of
water over the same burner,
but one of the pots is full of water
and the other is only about half full.
You would probably expect
the one with less water in it
to boil faster,
and this is actually because
of the heat capacity.
The pot with the less water in it
has a lower heat capacity.
And this is because one of the things
that heat capacity depends on
is the mass of the object or system.
Less water is less mass
xis a lower heat capacity.
The other thing that the
heat capacity depends on
is the material.
This is also something
you are probably already
intuitively familiar with.
Imagine you go to a barbecue on a hot day
and there are two folding chairs
left open for you to choose between.
One is made of metal,
the other of plastic,
and they've both been
sitting out in the sun.
You'd probably choose the plastic one
to save yourself some discomfort.
The reason that the metal
chair would be hotter
despite both chairs having
been sitting out in the sun
is because metal and plastic
are different materials
and have different heat capacities.
So we know that the heat
capacity of an object or system
depends on both the mass and
the material it is made of.
We can actually combine these then
into something called
specific heat capacity.
Now the specific heat capacity
is just the heat capacity per mass.
This means that the specific heat capacity
is independent of the mass of the system
because we're measuring it per mass.
Therefore, this is constant
for a given material.
This means it will take
the same amount of energy
to raise the temperature of 1 kilogram
of any given material,
but then for a different material,
it will take a different amount of energy.
Given this, what do you expect the units
of specific heat capacity to be?
Well, just like heat capacity,
we have an energy per temperature,
but now we also have a per mass.
In SI this is going to be
Joules per Kelvin per kilogram.
This means that the heat capacity
and the specific heat
capacity are related by mass.
so, if you have a specific heat capacity
and you want to get
the total heat capacity
for the object or system,
then you need to multiply by
the object or system's mass.
Conversely, if you have the
heat capacity and the mass
and you want to figure out
what the heat capacity of a material is,
you can divide the heat
capacity by the mass.
However, because specific heat capacity
is a constant property
of a given material,
we can usually just go ahead
and look up what that value is
because scientists have already measured
the specific heat capacities
of lots of materials.
Let's consider the water in
those pots we talked about.
Pure liquid water has a
specific heat capacity
of 4,184 Joules per Kelvin per kilogram,
but different materials
have different specific heat capacities.
So let's think back to our
chairs at a barbecue example
and how the metal chair is
hotter than the plastic chair.
Now metal folding chairs are
typically made of aluminum,
which has a specific heat capacity
of 897 Joules per Kelvin per kilogram.
Solid plastic, however,
has a specific heat capacity
of 1,670 Joules per Kelvin per kilogram.
So you can see from the
specific heat capacities
that since the sun is providing
the same amount of energy
to both chairs,
the temperature of the metal chair
is getting much more increased
because it needs less energy
to increase its temperature
because it has a lower
specific heat capacity.
Now that we see how the material
changes the heat capacity,
let's talk a bit more about the mass
and go back to our example of the pots.
So in these pots, we
have pure liquid water,
which we know now has a
specific heat capacity
of 4,184 Joules per Kelvin per kilogram.
Now the pots themselves
also have a heat capacity,
but we're going to ignore
that to simplify the problem.
If this pot has 2
kilograms of water in it,
we can calculate how
much energy it will take
to change the temperature of this water.
Let's say that the initial
temperature of the water
is about 300 Kelvin,
which is approximately room temperature.
And suppose we want to use this water
to make some white tea,
which has made best with water
that's at about 355 Kelvin.
Based off our understanding
of heat capacity now,
we can figure out how many
joules it is going to take
to raise the water from
300 Kelvin to 355 Kelvin.
We have the specific
heat capacity and a mass,
and we know we can multiply those
to get a total heat capacity.
And we know that by definition,
heat capacity is the energy
required per temperature,
which means that if we
multiply the heat capacity
by the change in temperature,
we'll find out what
the energy required is.
In fact, this relationship
is an important thermodynamic equation.
Lower case c is commonly used
for specific heat capacity
and Q for heat.
So this is exactly what
we've just worked out.
The heat or energy required
equals the specific heat
capacity times the mass,
times the change in temperature.
Let's go ahead and put our values in here.
The mass,
specific heat capacity,
and the change in temperature.
As always, we can use
our units to guide us.
Specific heat capacity
has a unit of Joules
per Kelvin per kilogram,
we're multiplying mass that
has a unit of kilograms,
so those kilograms will cancel out.
We're also multiplying by
a change in temperature,
which is measured Kelvin.
And so that will also cancel out,
leaving us just with
joules which is an energy,
just like we want.
In this case, if we
multiply this together,
we would find that the energy required
would be 460.24 kilojoules.
Now, let's consider the other pot.
If this pot has 1 kilogram of water,
how would that change our calculation?
Pause the video
and think about what its
heat capacity would be.
So because we still have the same material
and therefore the same
specific heat capacity,
the total heat capacity is
going to decrease by half
because of the mass is half.
And since we still want to
raise the water's temperature,
the same amount,
this means that the energy required
is going to decrease by half as well,
now requiring 230.12 kilojoules.
So now we can see how the mass,
as well as the material
affect heat capacity.
Today we talked about heat capacity.
We learned that it is the
amount of heat required
to change the temperature of a material
and that it is measured
in Joules per Kelvin,
and that it depends on
both the mass of the system
and the materials that
the system is made up.
We did a couple of examples
to help us quantify this
intuitive understanding we have
of the world around us.
And I encourage you
to think about the ways
he capacity pops up
in your everyday life.
For example, why are some
things drier than other things
when you unload the dishwasher?
Have a think about that.
Thank you so much for joining us.
I hope you learned a
little bit of something,
and we'll see you again next time. Bye.